um let's get to it most disrespected
figures in the national football league
today's draft chris you have a question
for me oh i do it's uh movie related i
know this is a movie you like okay uh
rodney dangerfield who played al
cervic in caddyshack i don't know if i
said that triple lindy all right yeah
what was his occupation
in the movie
he was a contractor he was like a
builder yeah all right we'll give it to
you construction yep service
construction land developer way to go
man you know you really i mean
i didn't know if you would get that but
i guess you do know that movie that well
the whole idea is rodney dangerfield
always said i don't get no respect so
that's the purpose of today's draft the
guys who were disrespected i think
there's a difference between
i think there's a it's subtle there's a
difference between not getting respect
and being affirmatively disrespected so
there's a subtlety there there is or as
you may say well a subtlety there well
so i'll let me show you how it's done
all right yes but i do think you're
right and i just want to make yeah
you're right because it's not about guys
that are underrated right that's what
you basically said that first one it's
about your disrespect
right how you disrespect me
on a daily basis with your work exactly
right constantly constantly the subject
of criticism that is unwarranted and i'm
gonna begin with a team that we were
just talking about but not the guy that
we were talking about my first pick in
this draft is mike tomlin one of the
finest coaches in all of football one of
the better coaches in the history of
football we've talked about this
recently when guys leave the steelers
guys who by all appearances hadn't been
a problem they go somewhere else and
there are problems like
why didn't we know about this we didn't
know about it because mike tomlin is
able to get his guys whoever they are
whatever their issues whatever their
problems whatever their personalities he
gets them all on the same page he gets
the most out of them he makes chicken
salad out of chicken you know what
especially last year like if they made
it to the playoffs last year he'd have
been the pft coach of the year yeah now
i couldn't make him the coach of the
year because they didn't make it to the
playoffs but he took a horrible
situation no le'veon bell no antonio
brown no ben roethlisberger and he
turned it into something that almost
took them to the playoffs and if they
had gotten to the playoffs they'd have
been dangerous in the playoffs they are
a dangerous team week in and week out
year in and year out and i think if he
had done
what he's done with any team other than
the steelers where we've come to expect
over the last 50 years that this is
going to be a good team we'd appreciate
it more yeah and what makes it
affirmative disrespect is you talk to
anybody in pittsburgh you talk to a
steelers fan they lose two games in a
row fire mike tom no doubt they they
fall out of the plow states fire my
tommen just wait just wait if they ever
fire mike tomlin wait and see what he
does somewhere else and wait and see
what his replacement does in pittsburgh
well i mean i'm really proud of you for
this pick it's a great pick i mean it
really is he's he's
easily one of the most disrespected
people coaches you know that we've seen
in the nfl over the last few years
there's no doubt about it an
unbelievable uh communicator you know
unbelievable at motivating guys and
doing all that and yeah they've had some
personalities up there and i'm proud of
you too because i mean i feel like when
i first got on this show you weren't
sure
what he was as a guy but i think you've
seen enough to go wait this guy is you
know kind of what you just explained so
way to self-scout yourself and realize
what a good coach and how disrespected
he is i like that i like that event
don't don't take credit don't take
credit for me changing my position
you're very you're very you're very in a
very nuanced way more nuanced than you
were capable of three years ago when you
started working with me you're trying to
take credit yes for my change of tune i
am i am trying to take credit you're
exactly right all right well i'm going
to somebody this off season right that i
just feel is disrespected dak prescott
he's going to be my first pick i mean
damn
i mean you know don't pay him the money
he doesn't deserve it
i mean oh jeez
god forbid he like drives a hard bargain
with like the richest owner in football
oh my gosh you know oh we should just
play with andy dalton this year what
what
like insanity for the guy who led
football and passing yards and one of
the most explosive arms in football
throwing the ball down the field listen
i understand if we want to push back
against the narrative of maybe he
shouldn't get 38 40 million dollars a
year okay that's cool but for the
narrative to have changed like can the
cowboys win without dick prescott is dak
press got a franchise quarterback yes
he's proved it for four years in a
freaking row so get over it and i just
don't like that so i feel like he has
been disrespected
yeah and he's disrespected by fans by
media and by the team that has refused
to pay him yeah now they're paying him
31.4 million this year we should all be
so underappreciated but they've refused
to give him that long-term contract that
he has earned all right next one for me
speaking of self-scouting myself get
your flower out you got your flower all
right oh baby bingo we have a bingo all
our producers thought you would pick him
oh they all called it before they all
said it so well he is he is less
respected even if i'm even if not i'm
one of the main he loves golfer kirk
cousins
is disrespected look last year and and
after he was openly disrespected does it
count though you're the ring leader of
the disrespecters does it count i don't
know
apparently you don't i don't care okay
but after he was disrespected by adam
thielen who called him out stefan diggs
who went awol for several days that did
something that that woke this guy up and
he had a great great statistical run
last year and he made you know the throw
of his career against the saints in
overtime of the playoffs and we we
talked to him at the super bowl how
uh that will potentially carry over you
know we've we've lost track of all that
this year because of the pandemic but
i i i think that now he's a great
example for what kirk cousins or for
what derek carr needs to do
kirk cousins takes the abuse and he gets
pissed about it but he doesn't go whine
about it he doesn't block people on
twitter about it he doesn't go curl up
in a ball and turn the light on and off
over and over again he goes out and he
shows you
i can do it i'm going to do it and i'm
going to stick it to you and that's what
derek carr needs to do what kirk cousins
did last year
when he was taking it both internally
and externally from all of us people
like me from stephon diggs and and and
adam theo and i guarantee you one of the
reasons stefan diggs isn't in minnesota
anymore it's because he and kirk cousins
just don't see eye to eye
i think that motivates him too and i
think he's been disrespected by
teammates by media
by fans and and this is maybe this is
his year maybe this is the year where he
takes it to the next level chris yeah i
i hope so but either way i mean your
point's real he has been disrespected
you know i you know the contract stuff
everything there i get it i get it i get
it i get it but he's still
top half of football starting
quarterback and yes at times for
whatever reason people talk about him
like he's one of the five worst
quarterbacks in football and that's
where it's not fair and um so wow i'm
i'm i'm impressed i'm impressed with you
so far really two good picks like you
know it's like chicken soup for the soul
here you're doing well you might have
won the draft already i'm not even sure
but here we go wow you're conceding well
yeah there's two good ones and you're
sure let's see what you got such great
you know self scouting um
i'm going with josh out going my boy
blue i'm going with josh allen yes i
mean josh allen no matter what he does
what he threw for 400 yards and ran for
100 yards and three touchdowns ah his
accuracy is a problem his accuracy is a
problem what he just made like 10
unbelievable throws that like nobody on
the planet can make you know oh wait
wait his team went to the playoffs oh oh
wait his team had a big lead in the
playoffs why oh because he was making
freakish-type plays out on the football
field to me
the the people won't let the theme of
what they saw in college go away from
josh allen i mean 500 yards rushing nine
touchdown passes team goes to the
playoffs you know challenges the
patriots in the afc east 20 touchdowns
nine interceptions yeah 58.8 percent
completion percentage okay he's not drew
brees he can do some other things that
drew brees can't do either so i just get
sick of hearing that crap all the time
he's a franchise guy he's a difference
maker and i just feel like he doesn't i
feel like you've heard me say this if
other people had some of his resume
already in the nfl i feel like we'd be
pumping them up a whole lot more than we
pump up josh allen
yeah i don't disagree with that and i'm
not surprised that you're you're you're
twisting the narrative to get into uh
one of your guys here's one i'm gonna do
my last one i could go a lot of
different ways i'm going adam gays the
jets okay you know that there's just
like it's like it is immediate like oh
he's terrible he's no good it's like
people he took the dolphins to the
playoffs his first year on the job there
and then it was one hardship after
another he never complained about it you
lose ryan tannehill you have your
schedule turned upside down by a
hurricane you've got this injury you've
got that injury you've got this guy
who's a malcontent you got that guy
who's a malcontent and then you come to
new york and you become manish met his
personal pin cushion for an entire year
and a half and jamal adams takes aim i
mean they were six and two last year the
final eight games of the year with
everything that went wrong for that team
last year sam darnold's got mono cj
mosley's out for the year they went six
and two down the stretch and and and
it's it's like there's this rush when's
he gonna get fired when's he gonna get
fired gotta get in fire it's like people
wake up and look at what this guy's done
as a head coach look at what he's done
with quarterbacks and look the
pressure's on him now because regardless
of the reality the narrative is yeah
it's there by a thread right
this is his chance to show everybody
that uh they're full of crap yeah i
don't get it either i don't i you know i
know we talked about this last week it
is it is
does not make sense to me the disrespect
that he gets certainly and yeah the
manish meta jumping on with jamal adams
and that crap that went on last week
added fuel to the fire and you know
you've heard me say drives me crazy
because the whole fan base up here was
going jamal adams is he's a poison he's
a cancer get him off of our team and
then he said that and they're like we
believe every word he says so yeah yeah
all right so make your pick i know
because i want to go rogers i want to go
carson wentz i'm very tempted but i'm
not going i'm going to eric b enemy okay
yeah the guy that's the offensive
coordinator for the kansas city chiefs
that you know can't really get a sniff
for being a head coach in football but
yet is a big part of coaching one of the
best offenses in football gosh he
coached adrian peterson back in the day
some through some of his best years of
his career i mean wherever he's gone
he's been great and nobody will give him
respect in the nfl and really give him a
little legitimate chance to get hired
and i don't like it especially when the
two guys previous to him as in peterson
and nagy get jobs right away and he
doesn't so he's been disrespected
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports